hello sir can you hear me yeah i can't
hear you coach what's going on hey not
much i'm just grateful that i'm not
following nathan great i'm very grateful
that i am before nate because uh i know
he's going to bring the house down what
do you think of what do you think of uh
ted lasso what do you think of his
coaching style david show what do you
think of that uh i love the tv show um
it its relation to reality is is
somewhat possibly uh distant
seven you can't coach soccer come on now
oh come on gosh oh i i can coach it i
don't think we'll have positive results
um but i i love the show i love the
actors
i love the the combination of
personalities it's just it's a lot of
fun do you have like that
a sign in your locker room like believe
or anything like that do you have
something similar that you've ever
posted in your coaching career
uh there's a sign that i i twisted a bit
of a quote from aristotle um okay i have
the locker room that just says
greatness is the result of repeated
intentional actions
um just just one of those things to
ponder on that great this is not the
result of just your talent creation is a
result of what you do every single day
now unfortunately for you or fortunately
for you is you probably have some
players in your locker room that could
call you out on that not being an
accurate quote of aristotle that's
that's the stanford thing right there
coach that's the disclaimer every single
time i bring it up this is not the exact
quote i twisted it for my own purposes
uh just to make sure because i know you
guys take philosophy classes here they
will see it and come back and find me
they'll call you out
ah yes the uh the the the uh vagaries
but also pleasures of being the head
coach at stanford football so um first
blush um coach is is that this
quarterback class that's coming out
isn't um
you know one of the best that we've seen
in some time and is kind of less than
would you agree with that assessment
going into the combine week
uh i i would agree that you don't have
the typical headliner you know at least
usually there's at least one headliner
if not two but there's some good ones
out there and and i'm
i'm a big fan of the quarterback coming
out of ole miss
i think he's got something special he's
got live legs he's got an accurate arm
he's got a strong arm i think he's going
to be one that
is that's got a chance to be a be a good
one no kidding so matt corral would be
if if we
if
and again um this is something that you
you might do at some point uh
making a list of
a quarterback board matt corral would be
the one on the top of your list david
shaw for the interview early on i you
know we haven't formally uh
i haven't formally started my right
pre-draft but just watching throughout
the year
watching teams that play well which i do
every year i always watch and see what
other offenses are doing and i got no
lane well over the years and like a lot
of things they do down there and this
kid can really make all the throws and
you know battle through some injuries
showed some toughness
but when he's healthy and and you put a
group around him you know he's got a
chance to be a playmaker okay because
the the concept that the the
nfl draft is kind of devoid of
difference-making quarterbacks certainly
right here and right now um that's
that's kind of a narrative that uh that
seems pretty solidified to me as i go to
the combine next week coach you know
yeah and i think there are it's there's
some other guys that are overshadowing
the quarterbacks i think you've got some
some really nice pass rushers you got
some big offensive linemen so
i think the top of the draft still has
some great players
um but we're all just used to having
some headliner at the quarterback but we
also know quarterbacks taken at the end
of round one all the way through round
three can be end up being really good
football players so um tell me about
this uh tibito kid i mean because that's
the conversation i guess that'll be
uh top of the draft either him or aidan
hutchinson what are your two cents on
that subject matter coach yeah you know
aidan gives you a little bit more length
um
uh but but kayvon is a
above-the-line pass rusher his quickness
his explosion
his variety of pass rush moves
um he's got some some freaky athletic
ability that
uh just ends up making plays um on on
sundays and
this kid's got it in spades david shaw
stanford university head football coach
here on the rich eisen show um so before
we get into some issues about coaching
and and college and things of that
nature um for for this you know talent
evaluation portion of the calendar and
everything that we're we're looking at
right now you're you're saying again
that if you're looking to hit that line
this is the draft for you you're in good
shape you need to protect your guy you
need to go hit that pass rusher this is
the one for you this draft first blush
for me that's what i've seen a lot of um
you know we all know that the running
back position has been devalued there's
some good backs uh that's that i've seen
but
the offensive linemen and past rushers
i think that's going to be a good a good
chunk of that first round and deservedly
so that kid out of michigan has two kids
out of michigan that
first glance just watched a couple plays
have some quickness and explosion
and we've all seen what happens uh if
you can get after the other team's
pastor you got a great chance to win
so uh i spoke to lovey smith the other
day sir and uh he was singing the
praises of davis mills and how
that this kid could you know absolutely
be their guy going into 2022.
um
and
uh as you all know with five
first-rounders last year and mac jones
doing what he did and
um everybody else with justin fields we
paid attention to that
group not mills do you think he can be
a real good if not championship starting
quarterback in the nfl david shaw for
the texans
you know
what davis did last year um didn't start
early played some games in the middle
and then finished up
uh he's arguably the second best
rookie quarterback this past year behind
back and in some places probably
performed outperformed back
this was part of our conversations with
davis whether or not he was going to
come back
because just as you mentioned this
quarterback class isn't great if davis
would have come back
i feel very strongly that he would be
the top quarterback in the draft so the
texans just got the top quarterback in
the draft a year ahead of when he would
have been top quarterback
so now here you've got the quarterback
that when you put the film on i watched
like the last five or six games that he
played this guy's as good as anybody in
the nfl in the red zone strong arm
better athlete than you think
um really bright kid smart kid picks it
up learn something from his mistakes um
i think they've got a legitimate starter
there that's got a chance to be the
franchise guy and hopefully they can put
some pieces around them and have some
fun down there in houston how's andrew
luck doing what's going on with him
what's up andrew luck is doing better
than all of us combined
he knows himself he's comfortable with
himself the rest of us would love to see
him go out there and sling it around
but his career is short
too short obviously but it was an
amazing experience for him and now he's
moved on he's a husband and a father and
looking for that next chapter in his
life what is it is that anything to do
with football do you think
uh i i'm not sure i'm not sure i think
he's got as you can imagine he's got a
million
opportunities
um but he's uh he's enjoying life and
he's taking his time i mean he's got you
know he's got 40 years to figure it out
a minimum so he's just one of those guys
that's looking at a lot of different
things he's been in touch with a lot of
different people
um i think when he does dive into his
next enterprise
it'll be something that benefits um
people
um so that's that's all i'm comfortable
saying right now i think he's a very
conscientious person and he's still
beyond football wants to make an impact
in our society and you know it
mccaffrey
after
absolutely tearing things up
can't stay healthy has an
inability to stay healthy and you know
that was the red flag the false red flag
was the business of not playing in your
bowl game that that that to me was a
false red flag from the beginning but
the red flag about him well running
between the tackles in this grown ass
man league could be a big problem for
him and now he is not finished up i'm
wondering what you make of his career to
this point
david shaw
i think it says a lot about the nfl um
and you know
he had one injury here in three years
at stanford um he ran a lot between the
tackles probably more than anybody in
the country for the most part um
but it's a it's a brutal leak and
you know things happen um i know one was
a hamstring which has nothing to do with
his size or contact
but i'll tell you this there's
not anybody else in the nfl that i would
bet
that i would bet more for
than christian caffrey
his mentality his offseason work
what i've heard about him taking care of
his body and preparing
um trust me he's uh he's gonna be ready
come august okay a few minutes left with
stanford head coach david shaw here on
the rich eisen show i don't usually ask
you this question directly but i'll just
do it anyway this time around is did you
get on any calls for head coaching
opportunities in the nfl does your phone
ring
at all
uh i take the fifth
okay you played the fifth okay
um you know cause i i think you'd be
i tell you this to your face and i tell
you this all the time and i talk about
you and you're not on the show i think
you would be
phenomenal
at that
um
endeavor should you ever choose to to do
it
you know the conversation about hiring
people of color is a significant one
right now and brian flores having sued
the league with mike tomlin having hired
him
um as his special defensive assistant do
you have any thoughts on the subject
matter that you'd like to share uh what
uh um a
fix for the lack of a phrase might be or
what the issue is
david shaw
yeah this is a tough one as you can
imagine i've answered this question a
million times
partially also because i'm the son of a
football coach my dad was
almost a head coach multiple times
so i'm well versed in this conversation
there are two
there are two
things that are hard to rectify together
first and foremost
is that when you are hiring someone no
one can tell you who to hire
right it just you have to be able to
hire the best person right
and for the rest of us
and i include all of us in this is
trying to make sure that we have
the best viable candidates regardless of
race um but has that has to be inclusive
that that group has to be grown
that that group has to have access to
um people in positions of of power
people who are hiring um there are a lot
of conversations about okay how do we
influence the decision makers how do we
you know and this is an off season where
two uh men of color were hired as
general managers
um and so that is a as a huge step up
there are a lot of
a lot of
all 32 teams a lot of them are very
diverse as far as race as far as
gender equity
the league has grown a lot in those
areas
the two big areas that show lacking
diversity
are ownership and head coaches
so that's a that's a really really
difficult thing
for us to push on um but from my
standpoint people i've talked to mike
loxes doing a great job in this area i
know the nfl has tried as well but
really having a groundswell of
legitimate
um
uh
people of color that have
the opportunity and the ability to be
head coaches and to have those people to
have access to the decision makers and
again i know how much you love stanford
and being there and your family loves
being there
um i'm wondering if you know the way
that the college football world is going
with transfer portals and nil deals and
attracting talent being so crucial to
have transfer portals opened up
and nil deals available does that change
the dynamic for you at stanford in any
way shape or form coach david i think
thankfully here at stanford
there's the the educational value is the
highest you can find
um in in college sports
so we we are attracting a different kind
of person that is not just short-sighted
as far as how much money can you put by
hand
but we have the long vision of this
education the people that i'm going to
meet the contacts i'm going to have the
off-season my internships that i'm going
to have are going to help influence the
rest of my life beyond somebody putting
cash in my hand
at the same time we are contributing uh
and educating our guys on nil
but i think we're one of those places
that's a little bit more protected than
others right because we have something
really really special off of the
football field right right but does it
matter that it might not lead to a more
w's than other places that don't have
that sort of uh dynamic
coach uh that's a that's a great
question coming off a difficult year for
us
um but i really like our team um i think
we've got one of the best quarterbacks
that we will be talking about next
year's draft okay
um we've got an outstanding group of of
skill positions around them i think one
of the best on the west coast between
receivers running backs and tight ends
so i think we have a chance to do some
really think special some special things
and i've always felt this
when stanford football wins college
football wins
right because here's an example that we
can have here right over our last decade
wouldn't be one of the top 10 winningest
programs in college football doing it
the right way doing it with scholar
athletes um doing it within the rules
and going out there and producing great
talent like two guys we've talked about
andrew lloyd christian mccaffrey solomon
thomas et cetera
we're doing it the right way and doing
it with right people and when we win i
believe college football wins all right
well i don't usually ask this question
on the air again of uh somebody else let
alone another happily married man but
i'm seeing you in vegas right we're
going to vegas together right yeah we're
we're working on it we're working on it
all right it looks like it fits in my
schedule and uh okay i hope to join you
all look coach i i just love our chats i
love getting to hang with you and
getting to pick your brain and being
around you and i just think uh the world
of you so and every single time you say
yes when i say come on the show i really
appreciate it so thank you
thanks anytime rich thanks man you're
the best you take care best of you and
your family that's coach david shaw
stanford football right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here